hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i wanted to
provide
an update on the whole being stuck
in australia thing um in part because i
keep feeling like talking about this
stuff
is helpful for any australians who are
trying to travel
but mostly because i think it's pretty
wild
and interesting um so i'm not stuck in
australia that's the good news
uh if you're watching this video it
means that i have successfully
left australia but boy was it difficult
um i had basically repeated
flight problems um which were kind of
expected um and some unexpected parts of
that
trying to get out of the country which
most people are not allowed to do so i
don't expect that a lot of people will
even be trying to do this because for
anyone who doesn't know
australian citizens are currently not
allowed to leave the country without a
permit
um that's not an issue for me because
australia class classifies me as being
a resident of another country so i'm
okay
getting the travel exemption that's not
an issue what got a lot more complicated
was not being able to get on a flight um
when i was supposed to so i flew from
brisbane to
sydney and couldn't
get on a plane to get out
um so i had to wait in sydney until
i could basically uh
and sydney's in lockdown
and i i first have to say because i've
had to like walk to get covered tests
for flights i went to the bank once
um a lot of people in sydney not wearing
masks
there's an outbreak here and it's delta
variant
and it seems like the rest of the
country is very concerned about sydney
but i would say like 50
of people in sydney are not wearing
masks
um really surprising because it's a
pretty significant find too
and just to see like how my australian
family is like
god damn it new south wales can you
contain this i understand they're
referring to the government
but being in sydney it's like wow you
you guys don't seem to care that much um
which is pretty nuts
uh so the rules of sydney's lockdowns
uh you can only go to places that are
essential and
thankfully they consider international
travel essentials so i am able to go to
the airport that is all okay
um which was definitely an initial
concern but the thing that i kind of
wanted to talk about was
i basically needed to try to get to a uh
or was trying to get to a u.s consulate
in australia for help getting back to
the us
i booked an appointment at the one in
melbourne um and it was before
melbourne was in lockdown for reference
that i booked it
and got an appointment which is actually
quite hard to do um you can't
necessarily get appointments very easily
so i did that
and i applied to
victoria state health which
is victoria is the state that melbourne
is in
um for an exemption to be able to go
there my exemption was like
this is super urgent i'm just trying to
get back to la i just need some help
um can i please come go to the consulate
and leave uh i have not been anywhere in
sydney nor in any hot spot areas i've
really been in
isolation the entire time that i've been
in sydney um
i've not seen anyone etc etc
victoria health actually just never
responded to my request to enter the
state
um which now seems kind of convenient
because they actually ended up closing
the consulate
so i did have an appointment the day
beforehand they shut the consulate down
anyway
because of covet um perth also has a
consulate
perth within like three hours denied my
request
to enter the state uh so i tried to go
to wa
uh western australia is where perth is
and again
um was declined entry to the state uh
based on my
reason not being an emergency enough um
which i get like obviously to me it
feels like an emergency then i'm like
i'm literally
just trying to get out of this country i
just need help um
and it's required i can get into more
detail for that
later like probably in a different video
but
uh perth declined me
so not able to go to western australia
so i was like okay um the consulate in
sydney isn't taking appointments until i
think it's like late october
i can't stay in a hotel in sydney
until october to try to get this help
so it was basically i there's something
that i need
to get um that only a us consulate can
help me with
and so i was like okay well let me at
least just try to go back to
queensland uh that way i can be with my
family while i figure this out i'm not
spending money on an apartment hotel
everything is just a little bit easier
if i can get back to my family
so i attempt to do that and
even though i have a queensland address
my driver's license has
my mom's address which is in queensland
so for
all intensive purposes i would appear as
a queensland resident
i was also declined entry to queensland
queensland does not have a consulate
unfortunately that would have made my
life a whole lot easier
um so basically it's like okay
because sydney's in lockdown and is
considered like a red zone hotspot
pretty much nationally uh i think there
are over a thousand cases which
perspective wise i completely understand
why this is happening i want to
reiterate that but
it coming from l.a the amount of cases
that we had
for a thousand to be considered bad is
is hard to
comprehend it's like australia has just
done a very good job of
actually keeping covered out
successfully most of the time
the uh excuse me uh
delta variant is very contagious and i
will say a thing about that
the way that australian news coverage is
able to approach
covert is very different to anything
that i imagine exists in the u.s truth
be told i
have not owned uh or watched any tv
channel since i moved to the us so i've
never actually watched american news
um they could be covering it this way i
just don't think they are
so they're very good at contact tracing
which means
you can tell the source of an outbreak
like
who it came from or where it came from
and then how it spread and at what
locations it spread
they're really good about doing that and
everywhere you go here you do have to
check in with an uh an app
so you have to scan a qr code before a
lot of businesses will even let you
enter the building
um so they can tell where everyone has
been and as far as i can tell everybody
does that i would like to just say
new south wales health you do not allow
american phone numbers on your app and i
don't have
an australian phone number i feel like
maybe you should
think about fixing that because i have
to use my mom's number for everything
and
uh someone mentioned to me they're being
a potential conflict with that because
it appears as though the same phone
number is in two states
just saying would be very helpful if you
allowed phone numbers that are not
australian as i don't
have one and i'm sure i'm not the only
person who's been like well i can't
sign up to this [ __ ] app because it
won't take
my phone number um anyway
i think that's generally how they do the
contact tracing and the way that the
delta variant spreads
there was this one report of it was
either a restaurant or a bar
and these people who weren't even
sitting close to each other and
covered got carried between the two of
them they were like the the entire room
apart
um it it's so
spreadable so contagious very airborne
so it's it's very interesting to see
um the way that australia purchased that
stuff to see like how contagious it is
um which is basically the situation
we're in so
yeah the situation that i ended up in
was
okay i'm in sydney i don't mind being in
lockdown
that doesn't actually bother me very
much but i'm having to spend money
until i can leave which i don't know
exactly when that will be
uh to stay in an apartment in a state
that i'm not from and it could be for a
really long time because
all the flights out started to get
cancelled which was
a very big part of my problem um
american airlines i think canceled every
flight between sydney and la
so i had this thing of that's why i was
like i really need to get out of here as
soon as [ __ ] possible which again if
you're watching this video
i am successfully out of sydney
um it didn't seem like i was going to
get stuck
it was just more hurdles were added
essentially like things just got
very difficult um but i feel like if i
were to stay longer
i would be stuck um if i were to stay
until
the the appointment opened up in the
city consulate in october
i think that australia would end up
walking down harder all flights would be
cancelled they would be stricter on
citizens leaving that even i maybe
wouldn't be allowed to leave and then i
would end up being completely stuck
in australia so i was like [ __ ] it i
have to just go
i have to just do everything that i
humanly can and figure out other avenues
to go
so i basically had a part-time job
talking to immigration lawyers and
flight attendants and
all of these other people who can help
me with my situation to try to get out
um it's it's very very complicated
uh but i have successfully left i really
hope so
my god there's a good chance that i go
to the airport and the flight's
cancelled my flight today has already
been delayed
which made me go oh no delay can often
lead to a cancellation
please don't do that to me so
sure hope that's not going to happen but
i guess we'll find out
um that's the bulk of the update yeah
there are parts of this that i'm
intentionally being vague about that
i'll probably be more comfortable
talking about um
once some of the hurdles that
i need to clear that do pertain to
u.s consulates um if that
is the the direction that i'm headed in
right now
um are concerned just i probably could
talk about it but i try to just be
careful with
things that pertain to that kind of
security essentially
um but yeah it's been it's been pretty
wild and extremely stressful and i'm
still glad i came home
it's the truth i'm still really really
glad that i came home
that i met my niece um
madeline she's the cutest thing in the
world that i got to be with my family
two days after you know a new family
member came into the world
i had such a wonderful time being home
and uh
i don't i don't regret it even if the
last two weeks has been
so incredibly stressful
uh it's okay it was worth it um and i
still recognize that overall i was very
lucky to be able to come home
um ended up being a hell of a lot more
expensive
than i hoped uh which
i'll have to figure out it's definitely
unfortunate
um of course the amount of youtube
videos i made definitely
declined twitch streams declined
dramatically
uh and also it is a lot harder to to
cover
anything on um youtube the same way that
i normally would when i'm not doing it
on the right time zone
um things are just always like way late
and and it's crazy how fast these these
cycles pass through when you're just you
know
17 hours ahead um
yeah i think that's the part that got
the most personally frustrating outside
of like leaving was probably
time zones working on us time started to
get a little bit tough
i think after two and a half months of
it which you started to
get to me i started to get just
headaches all the time and uh
don't definitely didn't want to do that
anymore so yeah that's basically the
update everybody
it's wild i hope that all my australians
stay safe and that you don't need to go
anywhere because they will decline you
unless somebody
is dead can't even go home
if you're in sydney you just have to
live in an apartment
or find a friend i suppose um
that i didn't want to go out of the
bubble of being near the airport
uh and i don't know anyone who lives
near here
it's wild because it feels like if i
couldn't afford to be in this apartment
i would just be homeless
what do you is there financial support
for people who get stuck in new south
wales
who don't live here i don't know
it's very intense but um
yes thank you all for watching uh new
people curious thought i'd give you an
update
sorry for being vague i'm sure i will
fill in those blanks later
but basically that is it for me today
everyone
have a good one bye